qu'il y aura un jour en france un congé
menstruel on pose cette question parce
que le gouvernement espagnol veut
instaurer justement ce congé est
monstrueux elle pour les femmes qui
souffrent de règles douloureuses je
voudrais faire un petit rappel être une
femme ce n'est pas une maladie les
règles n'ont pu ne sont pas une maladie
cependant incertaine c'est certainement
pas mal ça peut être très douloureux au
point qu'elles ne peuvent pas travailler
donc si ce n'est pas une maladie ça peut
tout de même engendrer des symptômes de
maladie est bas dans ce cas là bas vous
prenez un congé maladie et la belle
affaire et vous n'avez aucune obligation
de donner des détails c'est le secret
médical
car ce que vous disiez je disais alors
oui alors il écrit béatrice kaki des
noms je vais vous sûr qui dit non alors
je suis d'accord qu'il faut des congés
maladie pour des personnes qui sont
atteintes d'endométriose ou des choses
comme ça mais c'est particulier et ça
concerne une minorité quand même deux
femmes maintenant moi j'ai peur que
cette mesure dix souhaitent des patrons
encore une fois d'engager des femmes
parce qu'il est on se dire bon il ya
déjà le congé maternité il ya des gués
maintenant il ya les congés menstruel
finalement c'est un désavantage sa rampe
l'engagement d'une femme un désavantage
et donc je pense que c'est
contreproductif c'est ce qui a été dit
et j'ai vu un peu dans la presse et
attend à patrons demandent souvent à une
femme avez vous envie d'avoir des
enfants est ce que c'est un projet c'est
une question qui revient dans les
entretiens d'embauché et là ils voyaient
demandé avez-vous d'eric douloureux
problème
qui est une endométriose justement alors
ça qu'on sente pas une minorité ça
concerne énormément de ça une femme sur
dix est pas c'est pas reconnu enfin
c'est pas reconnu ces reconnu mais c'est
pas souvent cadrer faille à rien tout
est bizarre tout est flou etc et je peux
te dire qu'en cas de crise tu tiens pas
debout c'est ce que
retient on tient pas debout et un moment
donné il faut prendre cette maladie les
règles douloureuses pour parler français
règles douloureuses comme ça ni allant
de maîtrise ou peut-être autre chose ya
des filles qui sont plus sensibles que
d'autres eh ben on tient pas debout et
il faut le dire et en soit on peut pas
les forcer à travailler parce que moi je
le vis c'est très très dur donc donc
l'apport que justement on engage en lui
des finances est juste mais c'est ce que
ça il faut mettre un lier davantage
l'enseignement privé lutter il faut
lutter contre ça je suis d'accord avec
toi bien évidemment mais à un moment
donné voilà l'effet des enfants elle
adhérait alors mon mba qui s'y connaît
bien
oui je vais vous dire pourquoi attend
évidemment c'est un sujet qui m'était
totalement étranger mais il se trouve
qu'une de mes meilleures amies vivait ça
et elle avait ça s'est régulièrement
c'était laurent et moi elle est
elle restée la semaine au lit malade
mais d'une façon qui me choquait pas ce
que je comprenais pas trop bien ce qui
se passait et donc je suis pour ses
congés mensuel évidemment
même au japon où ils sont plutôt réputé
être un peu dur pour le travail voilà
donc saisi 900
hirohito oui
je vous colle wilko des rues tous les
mois mais vous imaginez 1940 à tignes on
se paye ce sont maintenant des très très
très très longtemps daniel moreau
conclure je réponds à béatrice il vaut
mieux que ce soit encadrée parce que
alors et je voudrais dire qu'il n'ya pas
que les femmes qui ont longtemps des
trios ce parce que moi je n'en n'avais
pas fait j'ai manqué énormément je me
suis évanoui combien de fois sur le
métro de new york non mais ça nous fait
vraiment vraiment eu ces violences hier
et je n'avais pas dans notre fille aux
donc ces avis a quand même alors c'est
peut-être minorité mais pour ces femmes
justement ml par exemple dans le service
public si vous manquez une journée vous
n'êtes vous n'êtes pas payé donc il
faudrait que ce soit encadrée parce que
toute façon une femme qui va manquer
tous les tous les mois parce qu'elle a
mal elle va être va être viré un moment
l'arrêt travail
je vous rejoins c'est d'ailleurs le
risque le risque c'est vrai qu'elle est
aujourd'hui a déjà des gouges là qu'ils
disent à des femmes est ce que vous avez
le projet d'avoir un enfant bientôt
machin ce qui est quand même très limite
de cotisation
trop génial comment
ça arrive ça arrive
plus tôt en journée mais ça reste un
scandale bien sûr deuxième chose après
la fille en l'occurrence il faudra pas
se plaindre de discrimination dire qu'il
ya juste un moment donné où les gens
m'ont dit ah bon elle est qu en savoir
trop de problèmes je vais pas la prendre
c'est un vrai risque de se passer
aujourd'hui vous pouvez faire un arrêt à
la raison